.
IT ITUESDAY, FAR
THRI
N WITH
S DRAFTED
SE MACHINE
PENTAGON, WE HAD KNOWN ABOUTN
HEHOMELAY.ANWE LEARNT
E LA
RIGHT NOW.SORKRTG  TRUMPHIMSELF
RESIDENTON
DIRECTED HIS LAWYER MA
CALL.
MR. TRUMP WANTED HIM T
LAND SECURCHN KEY SWING ES.  C
>> SOME OF THE WHITE R JANUARY E
UP, WE'RE TOLD, AND IT WASRU
WHO RIPPED THEM TO PIECES AND
THEY HAD TO  TAP TTIONALRC STAS
WEEK IN RESPONSE TSUBPOENA. IS S
COOPERATING WITH THE PROBE.
>> JOINING FORMER FR HOUSE COUE
PRESIDENT GEORGE
GONZALAN
YOU HEARD WHAT "TH IPHI TO
CALL MNES. REACTION?
N SURPRED
FRANKLY, JOHN.
S SAD THAT I FAT WAY
BUT GIVE TBEEN REPORAB
HAPPENED IP PRESND THAT PERITIM
RISED AT AE ANKLY.
IT IY
I SAID I THINK WEEKEND AFTER TR
ECTION KCTS AN IS IN DENIAL, A
UNFOUNNK GOOD THAT FIUALLY
HAPPENED.ETHER OR NOT
THERE ARE ANY CONSEQUENCES.
I THINK THER SOME
R THE ATTORNEY
GENERAIN OF
BE SOMETHING THAT THE DEPARTMENO
LET'S TALK ABOUTA LITTLE
INCRIMINATING ABOUT THIS
YES,OULD BE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S MINOR OVERNMENU
COMPARISO SSE IN FT APTLPAICNG S
A VERYER MATTER.
HE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WILLOO WHETHER OR NOT
AN HAVE BEEN
ECSO WE STILY USLY WHETHER
NOT A CRIMWAS COMMREINK E BEOR
ING DESCBED IS
K IT --  A PERSONALITY TOF
NDLIKE
CHILITNK IT IS
ACTUALLY -- WHO IS AER
AND IS SOMEONEO
AND I THK Y
, BUI TH, CERTAINLY TO THE
L TO THIS
IT MADE IT MORE DIFFIN BIDEN TO
HE'S -- PRESID
ALG O HAVEKIIS TVEUNFORTUNATE.
ERE THE ATTORNEYER
OR
WOD YOU A GRAND JURY?>> YOUW, I
HAVE MORE INFORMATION IN THE
AT THED NG TDEN
WH MERRICK GARLAND IS IN
AT, WHAT HISAR
M ANU DON'T KNOW.
T HAVE THE ANSWE OF PU INFORMAT.
A LOT MORE
THANDO
W, IF DONALD ND YO
P  TRIED TOW
A LONG TIME HE DID AND HE STYESA
, YOU D THAT
OVERTUED ELECTION,G RI
THERE.
I
LET'S B THE
AUTHORITY.
T HAVE THE AUTHORITY OR
ONOV
AND, AGAIN, THISR
INDICATION OF  INDIVIDUAL,UNWILE
OFORGIA SECRETARY OF STATE
AND ECFICIALE UNWILLING TOT TH
ENT OFISDOOUP
ONER
IOBVEIMPORTANT DECISION IISAT-
NOT IN AN TO MAKTH BUT YOU CANE
HELD THE JOB O
EDS F T
UN WDO YOU THINK, YOU
HAD THO YOU'RE
UNUE TO O
ABOUT THATM TELLING YOU THAT WHO
I  IOTHING  EVALUATING.ENT ON T
GRA I
AT I WANT YOU TO SPEAK YOUR
MIND.
I'M CURIOUS  AND O ITHE PUAPPRE.
HOW HIGH WOULD YOUR LEVEL OFHEA
E  TS UL, BA. Y WH IMPOSTO EN T,
AD TO HYPOTHETICN
PRESIDENT.T EATHISU KNOWULI WOUC
LET'S  ANYTHING UNTIHIIDENT.
MAE THESS EXACDOING.
AND THSS CONSECE
IND OFECI REALLY AO BE O
THERE ARE ANY IMPORTANT P RIW.
OBOUE TED CRUZ'S COMMENT ABOTHEM
SELECTION AND APPO
FROM SIDENOTION THAD'S AR
WRONG WH S IS -- MY INTENNOMIN
THERE IS NOTHINGNG, ININ MIN TH.
THM BETES SOMEONE WHO
NOMINATE A BLACKE COURT WHO IS
THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIEDD KE RESUY